-Jessica, thank you so much
for being here.
-Hi!
-And for doing the TikTok
Dance Challenge with me.
I'm happy
that you stayed with me
and that we're still friends
even past that.
-[ Laughs ]
-It was very embarrassing.
You were my guest on the show
early in the quarantine,
and, gosh,
we're now six months in.
I appreciate you doing the show.
How is everyone doing?
How's the fam?
-We are hanging in there.
-Good.
-We just started school.
-Oh, boy.
-Which is the opposite of fun.
Even just getting the kids
to bed is like --
I'm like, "Why are we having
a discussion
at 9:00 p.m., Haven?
You're 9 years old.
-9?
-You should be
going to bed at 7:00."
Yeah.
-Wait.
I heard that you guys took
a family RV trip,
and I want to know about this.
-We did.
I booked two trips,
meaning that we found houses
that are in two different states
and that were near water
so that we can do activities,
right?
-Great idea.
-And I've never really seen
the great outdoors.
I'm not really that person.
-No, me neither, but I feel like
I am somewhere in my soul.
-Somewhere in my soul,
I felt like maybe
I was more in tune
or I'd find myself in nature.
No, I didn't.
Nope.
Opposite of that one.
-Really?
-And, you know, I just feel like
some people should never
spend long periods of time
in cars or RVs or vans,
and that would be
my entire family.
-No one liked it?
-No -- The thing is, like,
it's just not natural, I guess,
for my children
to be in anything that moves,
'cause they immediately
start throwing up.
-[ Laughing ]
-Like, immediately.
So we stop in Zion,
and Hayes --
and I'm like, "Oh, my gosh.
We haven't had a kid barf
in like six hours,"
so I'm like, "Victory!"
-That's the goal.
-But then,
right when we stopped,
Hayes was like, "Mommy, uppy."
He says, "I'm full."
He was like,
"Uppy, uppy! I'm full!
So, I take him out of
the car-seat thingy,
and he booted
all over my fa--
In my mouth, in my eyeballs.
And everyone in the car -- in
the van was like "Ew!"
So they bolt out...
-The weird part is that --
The weirdest part
is that he's 15.
[ Both laugh ]
Come on, come on.
Can't we make jokes?
-You do, you do!
-[ Laughs ]
-So, kids are barfing,
and I'm, like,
trying to make
the situation good.
I'm like,
"Once we get to this --"
I was like, "I planned this trip
where we're gonna go see --"
It's an organic,
sustainable farm, right?
-Ah.
-But then...
First of all, the stench.
So, all my kids
have the smell of, like --
-This sounds like a nightmare.
-The smell and all the things.
-It's a farm.
-And then we go
to the chicken coop.
It's 112 degrees.
Right?
And my friend is so lovely.
And, literally, this is one of
the best, well-run,
most sustainable,
humane farms there are.
And then,
you open the coop thing,
and we saw an egg plop out...
-Nature.
-...and his eyes bugging out
of his head.
And did you know
there's like a slime...
-No, no.
No, no, there's not.
-There's like a bit
that comes out with it.
-No, no, there's not a thing.
-Yes, there's a bit.
-No, no, no, no.
Don't ruin -- Don't ruin eggs.
-He was like -- [ Gasps ]
-I'm like that, too.
I'm like, "What?"
Pal, I want to talk to you
about "L.A.'s Finest."
Season 2
is available on Spectrum.
And season 1 --
this is a big deal --
is gonna premiere on Fox.
-Yes.
-Literally national TV.
-So, it's basically,
take the "Bad Boys" universe,
with Martin Lawrence
and Will Smith...
-Yep.
-...and instead, you have me
and Gabrielle Union
and Gab's character from
"Bad Boys," coming into L.A.,
and we partner up,
and you just get to see
two women kicking butt,
having fun, cracking jokes.
And then, there's
lots of cool mystery
as we're really discovering
about each other's past.
-I can't think of two
more perfect combo
of you and Gabrielle Union,
because, gosh,
is she funny, as well.
-She is.
-You guys also produce the show.
What is the best part of
producing a show like this?
-I think what's so cool
about producing this show
is that you don't get to see
a lot of black and brown people
in positions of leadership
in Hollywood at all, right?
Behind the camera
or in front of the camera.
So, we're the leads
of a show, right?
So that in itself
is pretty rare for Hollywood.
And then, being leads of a show
in the action genre
and being women, again,
it's totally unprecedented,
and people just don't do it.
And then, also,
behind the camera, you know,
showrunners to
head of the writers' room,
and we kind of just prove
that you can have diversity
and inclusion behind the camera,
in front of the camera.
You can also write a show
that is inclusive
and represents diversity
in a way that doesn't
feed into a stereotype
or a stigma,
and you can be successful at it.
-Yeah.
-And it's still fun, and it's
great to watch for everyone.
You make a great show.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here are Jessica Alba
and Gabrielle Union
in "L.A.'s Finest."
Take a look.
-You, sir?
Drinks?
Private security, armed.
Front door, hallway.
-Okay?
-We need a distraction.
-Me? No.
That's your job.
-No.
-Hey, cocktails.
Mr. Jefferies wants you.
His friend likes to slum it
with the help.
-I thought I was just supposed
to serve drinks here.
-You've been promoted.
-Slum it.
-Slummin' it.
-I know.
That was excessive.
-I mean...
-As if.
-These guys would be lucky
to have some of this.
-All of that.
-Jessica, thank you so much
for being here.
Season two of "L.A.'s Finest"
is available now
to Spectrum Video subscribers,
and season 1 will have
its network broadcast premiere
this Monday,
at 8:00 p.m., on Fox.